hello everyone an old just check its 30
minutes speaking isn't it and then 10
minutes Q&A that's roughly right fine
I'll get a beating oh no on a beating on
a friendly word talk faster you've
already told me off or so I got told off
yesterday by Thomas first speaking too
fast in my lightning talk so actual
attempt to wind it back here and I do
want you to understand what I'm talking
about so if I do speak too fast just
wave for me till when it go slower it's
totally fine I don't want to cut you out
just because I'm getting exciting and
taught them too quick to that point am I
understandable add the back am i loud
enough and clear enough nods shakes no
nods great cool okay and another public
service announcement there's a signup
form on the front desk if you want to
volunteer to help the Berlin crew
organize the future meetups and the
conference next year I strongly urge you
of course given my lightning talk to to
contribute to the community so if you're
interested it's not binding you can back
out later if you want go and sign up on
the front desk right so I'm going to
talk on statistically solving sneezes
and sniffles this is a research project
that a few of us are running in London I
spoke on this at PI data London a couple
of weeks ago at our conference there and
this is a slightly updated version given
a little bit of work that in the last
couple of weeks so I gave the talk with
my colleague Giles so he's not here
didn't make it out and so I'm an
industrial data scientists I've been
working applying a I to industrial
problems for 15 years and my colleague
Giles is a bioinformatician turned into
a data scientist he's working with me
and model insights that's my consultancy
there's three of us in there and our
client in London a moment is a company
called in Dover there in the slides
because they were sponsoring us they
came in as a gold sponsor so I was
really happy to have them along to meet
the Python community and I've written
the high-performance python book with
O'Reilly so if you want to talk about
high-performance you're very welcome to
come in five questions a me
so my wife sneezes a lot she's really
bored of sneezing she's been sneezing
for 30 or years for a long time she
thought she was permanently ill and then
one day she had an antihistamine and she
was not ill anymore almost within like
two hours and then she realized that she
hadn't looked some kind of reaction and
a bed it was a persistent chronic
reaction so something was going on that
caused her to sneeze so then for two
decades she took antihistamines roughly
one every other day thinking hey that's
that's totally cool and somewhere in
there you know not sure taking a drug
every other day just so you can breathe
is cool maybe there's maybe there's some
underlying things going on that we
should try and solve and wouldn't you
know it I'm a data scientist so maybe we
could use data to somehow empower some
discovery so one of the goals of this
project is to see if we can understand
the drivers of allergic rhinitis or
rhinitis in general to give an
individual a chance to quantify the user
quantified self approach to measuring
their reactions to a thing could be
something that causes sneezing all other
things other any other reactions and can
you quantify enough things and then use
something like machine learning to try
to identify the things that are driving
the symptoms that you've got so
personalized medicine approach so we're
making this up as we go along this is a
totally novel piece of work for us and a
long term goal would be can we help
people reduce their need for medication
about ten to thirty percent of people in
the world have some kind of rhinitis
reaction often allergic but it can be
non-allergic so maybe you are allergic
to a cat or you have a non allergic
response to weather symptoms some drugs
these anticholinergics have recently
been linked to diseases like Alzheimer's
so although most of the antihistamines
are believed to be benign we don't know
what the long-term effect of taking them
is for your entire life and maybe taking
a drug every day for your entire life is
a bad thing maybe there's some
underlying things that are really bad
that we only discover much later like
Alzheimer's so if we can provide any
mechanism for someone understanding the
drivers of their symptoms
and changing their behavior that's
probably a good thing so I said that my
wife's needs is a lot so sure on the
left that's days where Emily sneezes a
number of times so she can sneeze zero
times that does occur like 20 days a
year or she can sneeze one time a day
for about 20 days of the year she
sneezes typically five or six times a
day and she can sneeze up to 26 times a
day it's a lot of sneezes these are days
when an antihistamine has been used or
has not been used so she's going to have
an antihistamine and sneeze 26 times a
day so she's sneezing a lot on the right
which days that she have an
antihistamine when it turns out roughly
half the days of the year she has no
idea his domain roughly half the day she
has one antihistamine and very rarely
she has to because her symptoms are so
bad so here's a hypothesis my wife Emily
suffers from non-allergic rhinitis we've
done some experiments with the cat with
me with other things trying to figure
out if there's an allergic driver
Emily's symptoms predate me and the cat
and living in London and other things so
we've pretty sure we are not allergic
drivers that leaves non-allergic
rhinitis and it turns out with rhinitis
there's the allergic condition which is
well under well fairly well understood
there's infectious you sneeze when
you've got a cold that's fairly well
understood and there's non-allergic
that's everything else and it's accepted
that it's poorly understood but some
things like whether unknown to influence
that so possibly the the use of
antihistamine is driven by whether
possibly alcohol makes things worse
Emily's noted that she's self-reported
she drinks alcohol and then maybe she
sneezes more pollution might be a factor
somebody in London suggested that maybe
I tried double-blind trials or placebos
on Emily to see if the antihistamines
are really working she would kill me if
I did that and I'm we don't believe that
antihistamines don't work we're very
confident they do works we're not
testing for where the antihistamines
work and I'll show you some data there
we want to know what drives the usage of
antihistamines in the first place so
Emily's a senior engineer and she works
in Mozilla so she's an iphone developer
so she can make an app to record this
data so
riddim an open-source iOS app whenever
she walks around it looks location
changes so I get a GPS trace when she
sneezes she presses a button when she
has an antihistamine she presses a
button she played to the cat she presses
a button so we get a really rich data
set over a year now of her behavior
where she is and what she's being
exposed to there was some fun data
collection issues that will occur I was
ranting about this a lunch so it turns
out Apple have a date time encoding they
have an epoch that is different to the
UNIX epoch of 1970s approximately two
thousand and one and a few days and
hours different which makes for fun
decoding we quickly switch to ISO 8601
the unambiguous state representation
format I implore upon you all please
whenever you doing datetime stuff use
iso 8601 it makes life easy and gps when
Emily's underground so on the london
underground transport system she has a
sneeze she tapped the button the gps
confidently reports you are at gps 0
comma 0 you've definitely there and
that's off the coast of africa she's
definitely not there so it's a bit weird
that the the OS confidently reports a
lie so there are these little fun things
always come out in these kind of
projects Owen there's m in reflection we
realized there was a bit of weak
experimental design that's hard to get
around we're looking positive events so
one sneeze once needs one sneeze if
there are no logs in a day does that
mean there are no sneezes or the phone
was left at home and Emily couldn't do
the logging so for frequent events like
sneezes we get lots of evidence as
pretty cool for infrequent things like
alcohol usage the lack of recording a
positive occurrence has an impact on the
experiments that we can run and there's
no good solution to this apart from
really logging with a camera trying to
monitor everything all the time I mean I
at that stage yet so just to remind you
Emily sneezes a lot and we want to
predict what drives antihistamine usage
so here's a log of a year's worth of
sneeze and antihistamine usage so the
timeline is April last year through to
march this year at the top these are
sneezes per day
so some days were typically five or six
needs a day you can see that bouncing
around you can see the 26 sneezes
mid-november some crazy bad day for who
knows what reason on the bottom chart
that looks like a barcode there's about
there's one line if an antihistamine was
taken in that day I don't represent two
antihistamines just when an
antihistamine is used so you get tight
packed regions around June that's where
antihistamines are being used a lot and
then there are regions at white that's
where antihistamines aren't being used
frequently so you can see it kind of
comes and goes in waves but there's
persistent sneezing and persistent
antihistamine usage throughout the year
there's also a gap in the middle of May
five days that's when we did or Emily
that an iOS upgrade and it hopefully
just deleted everything didn't say I'm
going to delete everything he just wiped
everything all the projects all the day
to all the everything we only lost five
days but it's kind of embarrassing after
that we started using segmento as an
external data log to avoid any future
data loss so you might ask is there
structure in this data and there is so
on this block we've got Monday through
to Sunday so this is a year's worth of
aggregated data looking at each day of
the week so monday through sunday by 24
hours of the day and a histogram per day
so it's the average behavior on a Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and we can see that at
8am there's a peak in sneezing so we
wake up Emily sits up she sneezes and
that's a very typical behavior and then
the sneezes drop off and then on
Saturday and Sunday we wake up an hour
later so the sneezes occur an hour later
so there is structure in this data the
sneeze has disappeared during the day
and then they tend to increase in the
evening we don't know why we're not the
biological reason for that is but we
observe that behavior it's very clear
that something is going on what about
antihistamine usage well it's a similar
behavior if emily wakes up and she's
sneezing a lot then she has an
antihistamine first thing in the morning
so we typically see antihistamine usage
first thing in the morning Saturday and
Sunday later in the morning kind of more
smudged out as well which is an
interesting thing we don't know why it
just works out that way and in the
evening if she's had a really
day and she can't breathe and she's
sneezing a lot shall have an
antihistamine so she can sleep well so
that's the antihistamines in the evening
and this bakes an interesting question
about the data if we're predicting what
drives antihistamine use is an 11pm
antihistamine driven by the day's
factors it probably is but the 8am
antihistamine is that driven by the data
comes factors probably not is it driven
by yesterday's factors probably but if
I'm predicting on a daily basis where do
I slide the data how do i how do I deal
with that and there is no straight
answer it depends on which question I'm
asking so do I find any obvious
relationships in the data well I can
tell you one that's going to be no
surprise sneezes an antihistamine usage
are related so here I've resampled the
data by three days this is a seaborne
using for the plots here so a seaborne a
freeze on Porter with pandas by three
days and then in three days if emily
uses no antihistamines as the left plot
if in three days uses one it's the next
one if in three days she has one end
histamine a day she uses three to the
third one or the fourth I'm sorry and
then on some rare occasion she's used to
add histamine to the days when the three
days she's used four in total so those
are the box spots and the y-axis is
sneeze is so when she's used no
antihistamines in three days also she
sneezed the least frequently because
whatever is driving the sneezing is not
that bad when she has three
antihistamines then the average number
of sneezes is higher and we can see a
linear relationship in there so it looks
like there's a nice relationship it's
not surprising right she sneezes a lot
she uses antihistamines it's not not the
biggest surprise if I didn't find that
relationship I'd be surprised because
that feels like it should be fundamental
and it's there so that's good and in the
bottom right plot I flip that around can
I fit a linear regression using sneezes
to predict antihistamine usage and it's
using a linear relationship to predict
an ordinal value so it's it's not super
great but we get a line through it
showing a linear relationship between
the
sir will the inputs and the response and
I validate that later was cross
validation so how long does an
antihistamine last for so this is the
nice bit of empirical work we can do on
the data so the left-hand plot there
we've taken 67 occurrences of
antihistamine being used in the morning
so if Emily wakes up sneezes take some
antihistamine we then look at the next
12 hours worth of data to see how many
sneezes she has per hour for 12 hours
just let Valentin but only in the
morning I will do in the morning because
i can't get 12 hours of trace if i take
the afternoon or the evening sneezes
because then we're asleep and then
there's no sneezing so only for morning
antihistamine use how many sneezes per
hour afterwards and we get this confused
plot not super easy to read the plot on
the right is the cumulative cumulative
charts so we just dumped summed up all
of these sneezes so on the 0th hour of
taking an enter so i take an
antihistamine right now Emily takes it
and then how many sneezes in the next
hour that's that large camps where the
mouse pointer is about 47 one hour later
similar number of high sneezes two hours
later it drops down massively and then
three four five hours later very low
number of sneezes and after about by the
eleventh hour things begin to get worse
again sneezes go up so the antihistamine
is effective takes about two hours
according to this to become effective
and then it's effective for most of the
data as great this antihistamine
loratadine works well for Emily great
the dotted line that's a simulation of
antihistamine distribution in the body
so it's a biological effect is that it
takes two hours to become distributed in
the body in the first place and then
there's an eight-hour half-life and it
drops off and to be of that exponential
drop off so it's nice takes two hours to
get into the body and it takes two hours
before we see it to take effect so if
you wanted to experiment with different
medications and different quantity of
medications perhaps you could do this
kind of experiment and look at the data
so this feels useful if one is trying
different drugs
so what kind of relationships might be
learn out of this so we know that
antihistamine is used roughly fifty
percent of the time so we've got a
binary classification for mollys we can
treat this as a binary classification
problem and that was the first attempt
that we we took on this data what can we
learn about what might drive the use of
antihistamines from external data
sources so can we use logistic
regression simplest possible classifier
that's very interpretable to feed in
some data about daily daily environment
and cut bored with their response
variable and testament used or not and
then using approaches like randomized
cross-validation says shuffling all the
data over the year not taking as a
linear time sequence but shuttling all
those days up trying to break any local
relationships and then doing cross fold
10-fold cross-validation looking to see
if we have a reliable prediction so do
any features give us a reliable
prediction what kind of features might
be used so on the Left we've got weather
so this is a plot of I think here
five-day resampled data to try and
amplify the effects so five days of lots
of antihistamines or few antihistamines
that's the turquoise thicker plot and
then the dotted lines is humidity on
those days so can we see a relationship
and you know not really it's kind of
hard to see that in that time series
plot but if we flip the data around into
a scatter plot we can see another linear
relationship it looks like there's a
relationship between humidity in this
case and number of antihistamines being
used on a five-day resample so that's
something we can test in the model and
on the right hand side I've got a
screenshot from the London air app this
is a think of the King's College project
think it's kings gathering data from
about 50 monitoring sites over London
looking at no.2 PM 2.5 and PM 10
particulates and then modeling London's
pollution as how it changes there on an
hourly basis so can we take that kind of
data and put it into the model as well
and see if pollution particulate
pollution is driving some of these
reactions so we take the raw data we put
it into pandas data frames we're taking
whether the weather important
Lee is coming from London City Airport
so it's not Emily's weather around
exactly where she is wherever she is in
London it's the weather from the airport
with a really good center set so the
features may or may not be correlated
just by distance we can take in this
case we also add in my fitness pal so
when alcohol was used and Emily logs it
in my fitness pal I wrote a scraper to
take the London waster system so the the
transport networks recordings they give
a PDF that you can look at to see when
you took certain transport methodologies
so I then take that and then using text
extract I pass that and then pull out
when different buses and trains were
used and the Northern Line is known as
being the blacks not line so it's got
lots of particulates in the air everyone
close their nose in it and then has
horrible robust not and that's a
well-known thing in London and so is it
the case of that kind of particular
pollution is driving something some kind
of reaction we take the war data on
hours or daily samples and then we do
things like make a three day rolling
average and a 10-day rolling average
they tried to smooth out the noise and
get a general trend difference in
direction so it's a are we decreasing on
our trend or increasing is there a
crossover and we create a number of
fabricated or synthetic features based
of the raw data so we go from about 20
original features to about 80 for
synthetic features in total with the
moving averages and the like and we've
got 330 rose worth of data so we've got
a pretty good data set to work off it's
not big data this is a tiny data set
this is killah bytes of data even though
I've added new features in so how do I
build a model well one of the two
approaches top-down bottom-up so I can
start by adding one feature at a time
and seeing which ones work and do
univariate feature selection that
identifies a bunch of features like the
humidity so that's great or recommen and
then see what happens now get a rubbish
model it's really unpredicted there are
too many confounders and I can use a
recursive feature elimination process to
pull out one feature at a time actually
I wrote erm a thing that tries all the
possible come
nations in all the possible ways with
many costs validations trying to see if
we exhaustively enumerate all the
possibilities can I come up with a a
good subset of features just to see what
what would come out of that and it keeps
on coming up with a simple answer Oh
before I get to that I've known that
answer now so on the one year model I
come up with a simple answer and the
simple answer is no features are
predictive over the course of one year
and this led me to the question at the
bottom given that i'm using things like
external weather and emily for a bunch
of months didn't have it didn't have a
permanent job she was freelancing so she
was working from home so she was
affected by the normal weather when she
took the job with Mozilla she was in an
air-conditioned office she's no longer
affected by the external humidity
because the internal humidity and
temperature difference and I'm recording
that and so we realized that there are
different weather effects going on so
what if we what if we sub some poor just
a portion of time and try and build a
model so if we take the portion of time
when emily is not in an air-conditioned
office and she was working from home and
she's affected by the weather which
we're taking as our inputs and the the
london general weather then i can build
a predictive model and it feels kind of
important so we see with logistic
regression sneezes the middle factor and
this is standardized data so it's a
strong positive wage the more sneezes
she makes in a day the more likely she
is to have an antihistamine so great
that the relationship I saw earlier when
it's come through I get a negative
relationship with humidity that damper
the air the higher the number the lower
the light curve antihistamine the dryer
the air the more likely the mucous
membranes get dry down to the more
likely an antihistamine so that's great
and I get this sea level pressure I
don't know what that's doing it as a bit
of a weird one but this feels this feels
like I've kind of discovered something
here that might actually affect her
symptoms might explain some of her
symptoms and this is actually a summary
of 5,000 independent models built with
cross-validation looking just to see if
the the coefficients in the model ever
cross the zero line was they stay on one
side of the zero line is a robust model
this is a little variant or just run
through very quickly if we want to look
at hell and the coefficients might vary
over time what if we train on AC
central piece of data so 60 days
training and then test on 40 days like
this mere test score that's one point on
the bottom chart and then I shift
forward one day and I test them or train
on 60 test on 40 I get a second point
that's the next point on the score chart
and we can see our predictive scores are
above zero above yep of fifty percent
dips down then it gets better if each
time we build one of those models you
pull the coefficients out put those
coefficients on the top chart and the
colors didn't come through very clearly
the smallest coefficient near the minus
one that's the humidity so humidity is
predictive for some number of months
Emily gets the job in turn a controlled
environment and then that relationship
goes away and it comes back again later
this feels like something I can discuss
with an academic and that's the
collaboration we got starting in three
weeks time so this is trying to pull out
explainable features over time to see
what sir what seems to be true see for
Alex periods of time when we've got good
data so can we do some new experiments
Emily doesn't go to work on weekends so
I can sub select weekend's over the
course of the year and see if she is not
affected by air conditioning on the
weekends and it turns out the model
holds true over the weekend's over the
course of a year so that gives further
evidence that maybe the humidity in this
case is affecting the things we didn't
gather consistent alcohol usage so I
couldn't make a good model of whether
alcohol increases the propensity to
sneeze so we've started a new 3-month
experiment every time emily drink
something she looks it inside the app
every time she drinks alcohol it's
logged in the app and we have a bayesian
modeling approach with another colleague
looking at that at home we've got a
hygrometer a digital blue air hygrometer
they've got an API but it's not public
so I'm asking them can I get the data
out of that if I get that I get humidity
for the home as well as for the street
outside and I can increase the quality
of my modeling and then the final point
about moving house will maybe being in
north london in a polluted environment
maybe that's a bad thing we're going to
move house shortly outside of London
maybe that changes symptoms maybe we can
see that just in the data log that'd be
kind of interesting so which tools to be
used we were doing some work at the
beginning with our so we used hdf5 for
data sharing
between pandas no pandas I live in
pandas for this Panthers is amazing
notebooks rendered on github with a
slacker channel so I can do some work
render it check it in and then my
colleagues can follow the link in slack
to the rendered diagram and see and get
without checking it out on running the
models so that's a really easy way to
share results in a private group if you
used versions data frame so I've
actually version the file names it will
all under get control so it's not
there's no super strong provenance but
at least there is a fully rebuildable
history behind this and if you haven't
come across in the notebook min the
author one of the authors of ipython
he's got some great channels the
scratchpad control be you get a
temporary window you can type commands
in or you can get the under the ipython
extensions you can get that little
button the M the arrow and the
underscore and that caused up a
temporary QT console please make working
almost like an IDE in the notebook
really easy so my strongly encourage you
to try those so where do we go next
we're on our second year of data
collection still with one person so we
want to expand this out so we've now got
several people using the apps we've got
several subjects recording different
symptoms they will all have different
drivers for their symptoms so that the
challenge gets harder and harder but hey
I get new data I can use things to think
about rather than trying to predict
daily antihistamine use what if we're
trying to predict three-day aggregate
use so if I aggregate my symptoms to
look at worse or better symptom days
maybe I get like an amplified response
and I can regress rather than classify I
have a question for you all I'm assuming
using logistic regression but one of the
assumptions of logistic regression is
that you have identically distributed an
independent data my weather data is not
iid today's weather is best predicted by
yesterday's weathers strongly correlated
pragmatically I get good predictive
results and I'm pretty happy with that
but I'm not I don't know the math behind
this I'm not sure I'm making the right
assumptions maybe some of you have
worked on this kind of problem with the
time series and strongly correlated data
building up individual predictors if so
I'd be very keen to have your feedback
afterwards we've got a collaboration
starting with University shortly
they don't know machine learning but
they know how the body works they can
validate if these assumptions that we're
making make sense that's this humidity
result does that really translate to
reality I'll be really interested at 23
weeks away so I hope it's true or a fool
a bit silly but we'll learn something
and the final thing is of course I could
strap sensors to Emily the whole Borg
ification project she's not terribly
keen on that but there's a big rise in
the Internet of Things sensors and
things like the atmo tube it's a seventy
dollar device you can hook it onto a
hand bag or backpack and it runs for a
month on Bluetooth Low Energy and it
records pollution and humidity so I can
get a month's worth of logging
unintrusive lee and we're only going to
see an increase in the sensors available
that we can either put on our clothing
our bags in our phones for logging this
kind of thing so it's a challenging
problem we believe that we found one
driver of the usage of antihistamines
for Emily and we've got a methodology
that's reproducible will validate it
with the academics and then hopefully
we've got the beginnings of something
that we can roll out to more people we
can answer the question are
antihistamines effective we can see that
we're not yet sure if alcohol is
affected by sneezes anecdotally we
believe that is the case and we don't
know for sure in terms of the data and
I've got no data yet to say the air
pollution is a driver of Emily's
allergies I want to find that because we
can do something about air pollution but
we haven't found that yet and these are
all the tools or the regular tools and
this wouldn't be possible this this was
all available so I give props to order
these projects for making this possible
thank you very much
do I have any questions thanks Ian yeah
um you were taking questions for 10
minutes now yes so I'm curious if it
would be possible to give your wife
antihistamine every morning and then see
whether as an effect on the sneezes or
not at least for like a trial period of
like a month or two right so we hid
there in the past she's gone through
phases are taking him antihistamine
every day only when symptoms are bad
before we started the study she was in
mean kind of that protective phase where
she was just taking them as a matter of
course every morning when waking up and
then we discussed it and said well if we
want to predict the driver antihistamine
usage you'd need to be only using them
when you need to use them so if you
don't switch to only using them when
required all I can really say is if we
if you takes one every morning her
frequency of sneezing will go down and
the concentration of the drug in the
blood stream will go up and i will learn
nothing about anything else although
although if I control for antihistamine
usage I will see variance in sneezing
per day like it maybe regression sneezes
rather than antihistamines but yes
knocked up the point of the project is
trying to use less antihistamine no more
so I prefer to keep that yeah hey sorry
I'm question actually I have a few
questions first one is is it possible to
make a blind trial sorry second is
possible to make a blind trial that says
that if she's taking the only well it is
bad it's correlated so it's not like
well so this sneezing something 66 or I
don't care about the sneezing per se I
care about what drives the decision to
take an antihistamine and that I must be
correlated with the factors that I want
to discover okay so I care about my
correlation because I want to find it
and the second thing is it may be likely
that well every chick is not the best
number you can
did you try making some asian models
that is I'm not trying to predict
sneezes okay I don't care about sneezes
okay I care about antihistamine use okay
sneezes it's the thing the course is
Emily to take an antihistamine so it's
that intermediate factor that I'm trying
to predict but one of the things we
record is the sneezes but i'm not trying
to regress some sneezes okay and the
scent and yet a bit of a weird one to
get we actually spent a lot of time
arguing we did try regressing on sneezes
having predicted antihistamine
concentrations because it felt like
sneezes was the right thing to try to
predict but then we realized there are
so many confounders in the way really
what matters is if emily has an
antihistamine what has happened in the
run-up to taking that event that might
drive that event and when on the days
when there are no antihistamines what
has happened before that might be
different the drives not taking an
antihistamine and that's what we're
trying to find can we can we manipulate
the environments to make taking an
antihistamine less likely there's a
consequence sneezing less likely and how
do we have more questions yes we do
thanks for the talk it was great I'm
curious about is the same antihistamine
used every time or have you tried
different types of antihistamines I know
that there's several available that
basically use different medical
approaches to solving that problem
saluting if another antihistamine is
used and Emily sneezes less for a couple
of hours we learn that that
antihistamine is a bit more effective we
don't learn what causes her to take an
antihistamine I would like her to never
take an antihistamine again because we
fixed the environment if it's the case
that running a hepa filter to remove
ninety-nine point nine seven percent of
particulates from the air solve the
problem and we've tried that experiment
that'll be great i can strap on to her
but we can at least somewhat clean the
air in the home for example and then
reduce the dirty air that was the driver
we've tried that experiment so I don't
really care which antihistamines are
more or less effective because they
don't solve the underlying problem I
want to solve the environmental factors
the calls the use of antihistamine in
the first place yeah and you
also tried different bedding or a
treasure for months ago we dumped the
old bed and we bought a new bed and to
histamine the sneeze behavior the same
we did also try so dust mites live in
all of our houses in our clothing you
can desiccate them at fifty percent
humidity so we then ran the humidity in
the house for three months add fifty
percent no change in behavior there then
we discovered the maybe humidity
actually affects the propensity to
sneeze and maybe fifty percent humidity
was drawing out him and his nose a bit
maybe that was a bad thing so we stopped
doing that tried quite a lot of
experiments the cat did not like being
shut out the bedroom for three months as
well she really didn't like that one any
other questions have you had any
experience with going on holiday so
maybe abroad leaving the country so in
an entirely different environment
absolutely so and when I mentioned the
beginnings that I'm fairly certain that
because some people have said hey and
maybe you're the cause of the the
allergies right so we've been together
for nine years and she's been sneezing
for 20 going on 30 so it's not just me
we used to live in Brighton she sneezed
there less so but it is sneeze in
Brighton and via this company in
previous companies she's worked in other
countries either with me out there or
with not me out there and she's been
working in Canada the US and throughout
Europe and for up to two or three weeks
at a time and although the antihistamine
usage varies a little bit it's basically
every other day it so the underlying use
of and histamine seems to stay which is
kind of interesting cuz that means
different pollens in the air different
pollution in the air different
foodstuffs different alcohol patterns
and yet this thing goes on so what the
heck is causing the sensitization and
but no date it must have the answer yeah
sorry and though you attract physical
activity or exercise second please
exercise or physical activity right so
and that's something we've discussed
with my fitness pal emily is logging her
exercise exercise stresses the immune
system and so there could be a driver
there
I haven't pulled the data out of my
fitness pal for that to see if that
correlates there's no emily has no
anecdotal direct notions of a
relationship between exercise and her
propensity to sneeze she doesn't
exercise every other days there's no
immediate relationship but they could be
a relationship one of the problems is
that myfitnesspal have no api somebody
wrote a python to scraper I updated it
to python 3 for anyone upgrading to
python 3 at every two hours and that's a
web-enabled thing with bites and all the
rest of it only two hours so I did that
and we got the food data out of my
fitness pal but the scraper didn't
include scraping the exercise data I've
written quite a lot of scrapers for this
so far I haven't written that scraper if
I don't someone else wants to ride that
scraper that'd be lovely but I agree
that's something to test I just haven't
tested it yet hello very interesting
collector especially for personal
reasons what is the result of allergy
tests of your wife because you try to
find environmental should be no bomb
normally around allergy tests to see
something can't you I don't think you
have mentioned and results so we haven't
done allergy tests Emily spoke with a
doctor and they said well unless you can
tell us what you're allergic to we can't
test for it and there's a billion things
we could test for so we're not going to
do it and that you've got a strong
suspicion and we said well we strongly
don't suspect that the cat or lactose or
dairy or other things which point at
least under the doctors that we've
spoken to this therefore there's no
point doing a test which is partly the
reason for going to see the academics
because the academics are offering to
open up some interesting links to people
who might know what the test and so that
feels like a far more structured way to
go than just going via the National
Health Service so we want to do that we
just haven't got to that yet so in
Germany you can get screening for all
sorts of allergies right you can just go
to the doctor and say I'd like to be
tested for like 50 different things and
they'll do it so maybe you should come
here and have the attitude early right
okay well you know the oral I new data
the advisors move to Jeff okay move the
German fine I might out of time I think
you are okay thank you very much let's
give it a go hand another
someone more time to eat